-My next guest is an Oscar
and Emmy-nominated actress
who stars in the Fox series
"9-1-1."
Season 4 premieres this Monday
at 8:00 p.m.
Here is the one and only
Angela Bassett.
Oh, come on, look at you.
-Hey!
-Oh, it's so great to see you.
Ah, you look great.
Thank you for coming on again.
I hope the family's all well.
Are your --
How old are the kids now?
Are they --
-They are soon to be 15
in just a couple of weeks.
In about two weeks,
they'll be 15 years old.
-Wow.
-Yeah. They're doing good.
-What's it like to quarantine
with two 14-year-olds
the past few months?
-You know, they spend
an extraordinary amount of time
in their rooms.
They did before quarantine.
But now with that in-school
Zooming, even more so.
So I kind of hardly see them
except at, like, dinner,
making breakfast.
-Yeah. They go, "Yeah,
we're good, Mom. We're good."
-Yeah, I think they're cool
with that.
-You've always done
this cool thing where you start
every post on social media
asking --
you say, "Everybody good?"
And this is before the pandemic,
before COVID.
And do you feel like
people are responding
to that now even more?
-Yeah. I find that they are.
I mean, they were before,
but even so now.
Some folks have gone through,
you know,
extraordinary, hard times.
So they appreciate just,
you know,
just that asking about
how everything's going.
-Last year was tough
for so many reasons,
but we also lost your good
friend, Chadwick Boseman.
But there's a story here
that you actually met
before "Black Panther."
Would you mind
telling the story?
-We did. We did.
Yeah, a number of years ago
I was -- I was so honored
to receive an honorary doctorate
from Howard University.
And so I'd go there.
It was a great time,
a great experience, whatever.
And, you know, life goes on.
You go back to doing your work.
And I get this movie,
you know, "Black Panther."
I'm sitting next to Chadwick.
Every morning we shared
the same makeup trailer,
same hair trailer.
So we spend hours and hours,
you know, prepping the day,
getting ready.
I'm watching him, you know,
call South Africa,
get his dialect right, you know.
And so the night of the
premiere -- glorious premiere.
You know, pinnacle of
just everything.
Cherry on top, whatever,
and I'm looking --
you know, getting ready
to leave, take the kids.
The only premiere
I've taken them --
one of the few premieres
I've taken them to.
We're getting ready to leave.
Let me go say hello,
and I find him
and give him an embrace.
It's just been incredible.
And he whispers in my ear.
He said, "When you got
your honorary degree,
I was the student that escorted
you throughout that day."
And I was just so blown away.
I couldn't believe that
he held that back from me...
-Wow, for the whole shooting.
-...until this very moment.
While we were shooting.
Yeah, the entire time.
But he shared that.
And, you know, so many times
you meet young people.
And they say, "Oh, I want to
work with you one day."
And you know that, you know,
you say, "Yeah, I hope so too."
But you know how rare
that can be, you know.
But we actually did.
We actually did work together.
-Do you remember years ago,
by the way,
you gave me a ride
to an awards show.
-It was after the Oscars
one night.
-Yeah. You remember that?
-Yeah. I think we shared
the same manager or something.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And we were in
the backseat together.
-I loved it.
I'll never forget it.
I was like, "You are -- I can't
believe I'm with Angela Bassett.
She's so cool."
-I've never forgotten it too,
because you were so cool.
You were as nice then
as you are now.
So yeah, I always remember
that too.
-We were doing some research
about you,
and I saw that your very first
TV gig, your first job,
was exactly 35 years ago
on a soap opera
called "Search for Tomorrow."
-Yes, "Search for Tomorrow,"
right out of drama school.
And I thought
it was such a big deal.
I think I had
a little, small role.
I think I was a nurse
and someone's sister,
big sister to someone.
-Yeah.
When was the last time
you saw it?
-35 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely.
-Well, we actually found
a clip of you
from a 1985 episode of
"Search for Tomorrow."
Watch this.
-Oh, my God.
-How's it going, Salina?
-Well, well, look what
the wind blew in.
Hmm?
-You're mad, right?
-Only dogs get mad.
-Okay, so you're angry?
-Do I look angry?
-What do you think?
-Well, by the look in your eye,
I'd say it's not one
of your better days.
-Oh, you read me right.
[ Laughter ]
-My voice is so high.
-Oh.
-"You read me right."
-And look at you now.
I want to talk about "9-1-1."
Season 4 premieres on Monday.
This show is all about
first responders.
So can you set up
what's going on this season?
'Cause it was a crazy episode
the end of last season.
-Yeah. Yeah.
At the end of last season,
you know, Athena was --
I mean,
she was brutally attacked.
And, of course,
she's been healing.
And the physical -- the physical
wounds have healed,
the face, the arm, whatever.
But what about her
emotionally, mentally?
That's where we're at.
But also, as we know
in this world, you know,
trauma and tragedy is
around each and every corner.
And as it opens up, there's been
this huge sort of, like,
break at
the Hollywood Reservoir,
and there's sludge and mudslides
that's taking down --
just taking down neighborhoods
and iconic signs and everything.
And first responders --
there's never a day off.
So either she's going to run in
and help
or she's going to retreat.
-Of course.
-And we see what happens.
-You do a great job.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Angela Bassett in
the season premiere of "9-1-1."
Take a look.
-They are not thinking on
their feet out there.
It's more like their elbows.
-Got an alarming call from
the emergency operations center.
They think those micro quakes
might've damaged
more than just the dam.
They're worried about a
landslide east of the reservoir.
-East of the reservoir.
Well, that's all residential.
You're going to need more boots
on the ground,
people to knock on doors.
-And someone to supervise
the scene.
Look, I know you said
you wanted to ease in,
but I need you back out there.
-Angela Bassett.
Season 4 of "9-1-1" premieres
Monday at 8:00 p.m. on Fox.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You know I love you.